vous
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants beaufoy patron
raconter leur la suite des aventures du
petit cornichons moi je descends leur
montrer le lit dakar 2 nov
pour les jeunes bobos propos cornichons
et le gros bûcherons sont devenus
inséparables notre petit ami ed de son
mieux le bûcheron tué près nounours je
suis prêt pas trop vous pouvez raconter
à vos patrons
à présent c'est l'automne c'est quoi
l'automne annonce l'automne vient pour
l'étude du côlon oui et c'est un auteur
que les feuilles elles toutes disent ah
mais oui les feuilles tombent
et pourtant la forêt n'a jamais été
aussi belle
les arbres sont de toutes les couleurs
et notre petit ami corniche on s'amuse à
faire de gros tas de feuilles mortes
il ramasse des pommes de pin il joue
aussi avec juliette à son hibou il lance
en l'air une pomme de pain que jude
l'état rattrape comme une balle en écho
qui cette juliette à le bûcheron un peu
plus loin si des grosses branches
cornichons que dans quelques bons
champignons pour le dîner le petit
garçon ramassent quelques cailloux bien
rond qu'ils déposent à terre dans son
mouchoir
le nom des champignons cornichons lui
crie le bûcheron et notre petit ami
ramasse encore quelques cailloux bien
rond au à l'umq en nylon il est l'heure
d'aller dîner dit le bûcheron qui
s'arrêtent de travailler et cornichons
emporte son mouchoir plein de cailloux
mais juliette à qui sait bien que son
petit ami est un peu dans la lune
cueille vite un énorme champignon brin
tout rond oh le beau simple guy le
bûcheron quand elle le pose sur la table
dans leur cabane en bois
le bûcheron le fait cuire dans la
cheminée sur la braise et ensuite tous
les trois ils se régalent s'ennuie pas
ce que ça a l'air bon dès qu'ils ont
fini de dîner ils vont sagement se
coucher évidemment
et notre petit ami s'endort bien vite en
pensant à sa maman à son papa et à son
cheval dada tandis que juliette à peille
fidèlement sur lui
allons les enfants l'histoire est finie
nous allons nous coucher tout de suite
mais nous y voilà
ce qu'ils sont gentils mais à mme cochet
tenue de nuit bonne nuit les petits la
j'éteins la lumière à dom
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors les enfants
l'histoire vous a plu oui eh bien allez
vite vous coucher
on n'y va pas trop en route mon cher
nounours d'un ennemi fait pour
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en vo
[Musique]